foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
what's going on guys
sorry we two three minutes late but you
know what this is free content we can't
be two or three minutes late Nate
nothing you guys can do about it besides
harass me in the comment sections but
you guys will do uh welcome to the
attitude we talk about the past present
and future game I got I got dirt
griggity here man what's going on there
what you been playing you know because
we actually play games in these streets
yeah man I just finished death Loop
sucker I finished that flip you jive
turkey
um I actually enjoyed it once I
understood what the hell I had to do I
got it and I loved it because at first I
was like whoa what the hell is going on
but once I got it I I love it one thing
I will say about uh death Loop is it's a
very
which I'm looking for
it takes a minute to realize like it
looks like this huge expansive world
they're giving you all this freedom but
like at the end of the day
that is the best game I've ever seen
shout from the top of every clip that
we're giving you personality and freedom
to do whatever the hell you want and
then once you beat the game you realize
there was no freedom in that game
the developers made you do exactly what
you were supposed to do it's cool I
actually really enjoyed that loop I
thought that I enjoy yourself I enjoyed
it I finished it and um Arcane is Arcane
though I love their games and like I
said once I understood exactly what was
going on I said oh okay I mean there's a
lot of going back and you know kind of
like playing over the same levels but
they make it to where that's it's okay
you know what I'm saying like with the
time difference is yeah it's it's fun
right you know certain things that
changes like the what actually happens
and that yeah it does yeah sweet yeah
it's sweet man you know so yeah all
right enjoyed it yeah so I I do just for
for you suckers no you know uh suckers
suckers you know what you know just to
talk a little bit about death Loop like
the banter between him and Juliet
Juliana or Julianne I can't remember her
name Juliana Juliana is some of the best
bantering I've seen back and forth in
gaming it's like I told you to contrast
to each other yeah what I like is like
the character progression one of them's
calm one of them is cocky and then one
of them's panicking one of them's cocky
which you know uh Cole uh he he's
panicking throughout the whole game just
about
Juliana's cocky because she knows what's
going on and I like how that that
relationship starts to flip towards like
the middle of the end of the game where
Julianne is like okay none of them
people made it this far he this one's
different like
none of the Cults
so you know I actually uh I really
respect that so you know we got a a
pretty big show for you guys man you
know let me let me say the topics uh try
trying to get used to actually talking
in this thing because you know what's
funny it's only been a week but it feels
like it's been a century since I've been
on here all right so we're going to talk
about
a bunch of stuff today man we're going
to talk about E3 returning
uh you know briefly go over that I like
to put some small small topics in here
talk about these Halo massive rumors
which uh dirt have you heard it heard
about those massive rumors so we'll get
to that here in a second uh Stadium
blame it Xbox for the downfall Stadium
uh Playstation Stars which I I think
what I wanted to name it PlayStation
Pace but paid stars and then a
PlayStation on remaking titles because
it seems like uh you know where money is
to be made they will they will squeeze
that grape into the last drop so as I
said what's going on you guys gave me
out here with dark gray getting talk
about the past few future the past
present future of gaming uh you know
first thing I think we're gonna talk
about man is this E3 returns I think
it's small um first thing I want to say
just be a little petty just a little
petty you know just sprinkle a little
bit of pettius
how does it feel
for everyone saying E3 was dead because
PlayStation wasn't there they they
closed the doors because PlayStation no
longer was interested in being in the E3
event and now we see it's coming back
next year and not only is it coming back
but it's going to be uh it's going to be
an in-person thing how do you feel about
that
it's great man you know I'm I'm actually
going to try to go man um I was thinking
about it should I try to go yeah we'll
be I should try man so I'm gonna try to
um
you know I don't know I like maybe I'll
talk to you guys to see you know like
where you guys usually book in the air
you know I know the area you know like
downtown or whatever Los Angeles
wherever it is or close or you know I'm
just yeah I think about going man so uh
because I've I've never experienced it
and I would love to I've never been to
California either so I would love to go
yeah and visit you know and like meet
some of you guys in person you know a
bunch of I think I went to 2016 17. I
missed 18 I went to 19. so I've built up
four e3s I think I just counted
yeah yeah I missed the year they
announced all the studio being bought
that was one of the best Xbox e3s
since the 360 generation maybe and you
know what was funny
because when we don't go we always react
to it so next year there will be no
reacting like there would be just a live
show I hope you do their live show later
on that day uh but the funny thing about
the whole matter is I was live reacting
with Planet Xbox kid smooth jazz uh 77
uh frog and Mark flipped anything he's
definitely he definitely flipped but we
ain't gonna talk about that but um so
we were having this conversation and and
kids move was a little bit ahead of us
you know he's a little bit ahead of us
so it was funny I remember is I remember
because I was actually watching part of
it or afterwards I watched but I
remember your story it's smooth is
screaming from the top of his life I
remember and you can hear me on it
saying shut up shut up I remember you
because he was ruining he was like
negative yeah I remember that bro I
remember and so you know uh we're going
through that you know what I actually
thought about doing
having a planet Xbox reaction to od3s
yeah yeah but I I've actually done that
before like for example in 2016 E3 bro
we okay like me and my boy Sean we
reacted to some of the terrible 360 e3s
like 2012 20 2011 where they was all
about connect bro we watched it like oh
my God we could tell what direction the
Xbox was headed with some of those e3s
towards the end of the 360 generation
they were brutal but it was funny just
going back and looking at it knowing
what we know now you know what I'm
saying so you basically definitely do
that man I think and it was funny
because people seem to be interested in
it so you so you should definitely do
that man it'd be fun all right so I want
to apologize to the time step Mafia I
completely forgot to put the E3 time
stamp in there oh snap I'm putting 15
minutes don't come at me okay I think
we've been talking about this for three
minutes I can no longer confirm or deny
that so what we're gonna do is um you
guys are gonna deal with the 15 minute
and we will go on from there just don't
don't put me in two feet under and I'll
say I see two feet because they're not
gonna take the time to dig a six feet
great 12 feet they're gonna dig me two
feet under and then they're gonna get
caught for killing me because they dig
me two feet under they going to jail
that is the future for the time step
Mafia because they're not the real Mafia
they're the time stamp Mafia anyway
let's I understand I I think E3 is one
of those things where it's extremely
important for the industry and I know a
lot of people they only look at it from
the from the the conferences part oh
this conference was bad all that
conference was bad this conference is
good they're not seeing what's going on
behind closed doors they're not seeing
all the work that's going on behind
closed doors because there's a lot that
goes into to E3 that has nothing to do
with the internet
all right and one of the good things
about Gamescom about the uh about E3
about Tokyo game show the pair show is
all the people for the most part in that
region
are going to be in that particular part
and that's that's what you're seeing
here is Imagine taking like a conference
out E3 is generally the one where people
aim for the most because it's in one of
the the biggest
uh you know areas that gaming has done
is in the United States well you know
the content the North America in general
and people don't realize
it is so much easier to get stuff done
when you know that the people you're
trying to work with is there
uh when you go like the Activision thing
you know what Activision just recently
did this model Warfare thing they had to
fly every person that they wanted to to
collab with to them to do that obviously
that's a different scenario they're
probably still going to have to do that
because you know they they need a
controlled environment uh right for for
for that to actually work but when you
go to these media outlets and stuff
when you go to E3 some of the biggest
show floors is Media IGN got like two
big booths you know GameStop I can't
remember if they ever had posts but yo
GameStop yeah games uh not games games
spot oh spot okay so it's just like
and and then we're looking at it for
just the meeting now look at it from
the influencer and publisher relations
when you're looking at from a standpoint
like that it's easier to work with
people you like I said you know it's
going to be there when you can send an
email and said yo are you going to be at
E3 sure there's a chance they might not
coming but if they're a prompted
influencer and they cover news and stuff
and that's their bread and butter
chances are they're going to be there if
they're not there on their own according
they're being hired to run something on
someone else's according so all the big
people are there all in one location I
think people don't realize how
beneficial that is to the industry
sometimes it takes okay okay being
someone that's communicated with PR
communicate with e APR Ubisoft PR Xbox
PR that stuff is time consuming
extremely time consuming you guys just
see okay uh you know IOP had obsidian on
you didn't see the three months we took
into getting that interview set up
you know it's it's very time consuming
and I don't think people realize
the accessibility of e3 makes it for
companies to reach out to people
um you know obviously the FSA or what
the ESP whatever they're called Esa they
they tripping and they needed to go so
all they're under a new leadership did
you see did you see what they're doing
it's like two days of Industry only
no and I didn't really see the detail
yeah two days of Industry only which I
think it's like a Thursday or Friday I
don't remember the days go go put in the
comment section I know one of you know
it I don't remember it and then two
additional days for just the community
like for anyone that hires so that's a
good middle ground I think that's a
solid Middle Ground gotta find all the
super jump from cobweb
I'm going to E3 hopefully I can catch
some of you in person as well my wife
coming but she's just going for me yeah
well look call me all right
all I'm telling you is if the only way
you can go is that the wife goes and
obviously you gotta you gotta do that uh
I would make that more of like a
sightseeing and try to make the E3 thing
like
a side thing that you do because here's
the thing I've been enough to see people
bring their significant others and with
them
if one person doesn't want to go it's
going to ruin the experience for both of
you so if if you can't go by yourself
I would try to do more sightseeing than
anything else because if the wife happy
you're going to be happy there
and sometimes you know these women they
they 100 behind us man they'll go with
this just because they know that we want
to go to these things but they don't
want to go to these things yeah that's
how my wife is man she don't really want
to go but she's like oh I definitely but
that's why I just leave you in a hotel
when it's time for the show and [ __ ] I
mean you know how many customers I'm
sorry it's about uh yeah so yeah so you
know that's just my opinion uh cubweave
uh it's just one of those things that
you know if you're if your wife's a huge
gamer yeah definitely take her I just
would hate for your first experience to
be like really watered down because your
wife just isn't enjoying the the
activities that's going on because it's
Heavenly gaming and if you think you're
gonna go there and play games think
again it's not that kind of a thing
you're going to be waiting in line for a
an hour hour and a half there was a four
hour waiting time to play sea of Thieves
what see these was it was ridiculous and
and you know we actually had someone
pull us to the front
so I can't imagine you sitting there
you've been waiting for three hours and
you at that front line you you can
almost taste the waters and see a
thieves and then some four big dudes
coming right at the behind the thing
they bring in some big shot with them
and he's like oh no these people are
next
but like I I remember cold cold uh code
vein
all right uh I we we had media for packs
I remember probably went up there
and I was talking to the pr and I showed
my my uh media badge
this dude was mid what to the last stage
midwalk
and this media dude was Gangsta he
walked up there he's like no you got to
go back he's like uh like he could tell
he was confused he's like we got media
we got VIPs they got to try this game
out
and then we we did another uh publishing
thing at PAX East where there was like
six people on on the stations they
cleared the whole station like the whole
unit imagine like I'm sure you've seen
like pictures of like the Zelda thing
where there's like a bunch of different
uh computers and a bunch of different
monitors and like set up in like a
little station we literally said we're
here for our appointment they looked at
like 15 people playing their games they
said you guys gonna have to go you guys
you got to leave you don't have to go
home but you can't stay here
and they made every one of them get off
the game and come back in 30 minutes
and so yeah I I if I tell you going to
these things as media definitely helps
uh another five dollar super traffic
probably not that I can't uh can't go by
myself I don't want to be by myself plus
we have friends in the air oh then that
that makes it even worth it many you
know it's expensive room and board is to
go to these things it's a lot of money
it's not cheap man you definitely man
it's like I said man I would try to you
know for every one thing you do gaming
wise if she's not a game I try to do two
things that that that's that's you and
her was
that way when you when you ask the next
day yo can we wait in this line for two
hours She Gonna Roll her eyes at you
don't let E3 result in a divorce fam
don't let eat through yourself in the
divorce
all right so you know are you excited
for E3 is it I personally like my
information being in one week that's
what I like I don't like this over the
the vast majority of like four or five
months we get information I like it all
in one week
that's what I like
uh let me read I'm good on money but
yeah my wife is cool but she isn't good
uh but she ain't gonna act like that
that's cool man that's cool I'm just
telling you my experience from being
around people uh that bring their
significant other you know I just I just
want you to have the best time because I
think everyone E3 is not something that
you need to go to every year unless
you're covering news it's just not but
it's definitely one of those things if
you can go one time and your life allows
you to you should at least try to
experience that one time
mm-hmm
so what that's what I want to do I want
to go once you know just to experience
it live you know the Xbox conference
this experience it live you know what
I'm saying to see feel on stage to see
people on stage to see the games on the
big screen I want to experience that at
least once in my life yeah I was there
for the stage of K
uh two announcement I'm pretty sure
uh I think I was there for the state
that came rehash announcement as well
I was there for the Xbox series uh the
Xbox One X uh announcement I might have
been there for the series X I can't
remember or not I don't think they did
it I don't know no no I I sadly the
Fable stuff was during the the covet
stuff I didn't get to see any of that
live because it is different being there
live it is different being their life
you know you feel the energy going
through you you feel the energy going
through the room uh you know and Xbox
they kind of they pat in the room a
little bit you know they they let the
people that do Fan Fest which I I've
only been part of Fan Fest twice the
rest I haven't uh but they let the
people that do Fan Fest sit in the
middle of the room where all the
microphones are so like when you're
hearing people scream yo what's going on
like that that is from Fan Fest that's
where the 10 dogs are the megatrons are
you know I never get that VIP access I
don't get to go past the the golden door
man they're like addicts you get the did
you get the did you win the lottery no
okay you're gonna sit in the back
there's a place back there for you you
ain't up here you know it's but what I
will say
is the first E3 I went to
I was able to go to the actual show
floor because of Microsoft and I could
never
I can never take that from them because
at the very first ether I went to was
close to the public
uh but because I got into Fan Fest they
gave you access to E3
okay and that is something that you
can't
you can't replicate going to these
events right like and one of the biggest
things that people always say yo addict
how do I grow how do I get access to
more stuff in the industry these events
when PAX East comes open you'll be Sur
now E3 is different you need you need
numbers even the IOP don't have numbers
that we need to truly hit E3 like we
want to like a lot of e3s about the big
shots the people that get millions and
millions of views a month but you know
obviously hopefully this time going we
got a little bit you know we we we we
pack a little bit of a punch maybe not
as much as I'd like but we we can hit
back now but um yeah you know gaming uh
Forte with the two dollar super trap
more games for more people damn I love
gaming I appreciate that Forte so it's
just like they had a great tweet man you
got to watch this tweet yeah but you see
it's like I saw two minutes long yeah
Forte you're gonna have to hit me up how
you got your camera looking so crisp I
can see the spose in your hand
it was like it looked magnificent man it
looked magnificent it was like one of
those things that I see and I think you
working for IGN games but
Forte explained to me how you did that
but it's like I said it's it's one of
those things where
if you go to these events especially Pax
wise past East I don't know if they're
doing South anymore uh you know you go
to these smaller events like uh like
Comic-Con even gamings and Comic-Con to
some point uh same thing with EVO like
you'll be surprised at being in person
has a huge what's all I'm looking for
oh it just hit different because when
you can actually see these PR people in
person and what uh what college showed
me is the uh not necessarily guilt
tripping uh but you know you get that
picture with them you know you you pull
up on like like a big influencer a big
person in the media and you know because
uh for the most part people in the
industry are very open having their
picture taken you know what I'm saying
and you get that picture with them when
you hit them up months and months and
months later to come on the show you you
put that picture in the Tweet because
they're gonna see that picture be like
okay first off if they're going to these
events they're taking this seriously to
some degree so they're going to take you
more seriously than the 800 other people
asking them to come on their show that's
never that's never seen them in person
or met them in person
when you go to these Developers
you know
Developers
are very passionate about their work
most the time when you go to E3 it's
always going to be like a representation
company someone that they hired as a
third party thing just to to represent
their brand it's not necessarily anyone
in the company it's like a temp agency
PAX East Pax West different
everyone on that floor for the most part
now there are obviously some you know
the big third party people they will
still do hire a temp agency but a lot of
these developers you can meet the actual
developer and if you go up there and you
just show a lot of substance that you
that you cover content in general you
don't even have to have a media badge
I've seen occasions where they still
give you the interview just because they
see the passion and they want you to
cover their product like these events
are extremely important to go to if you
want to grow on YouTube Because when
you're actually meeting the I've always
said it you got it you gotta
there's certain subjects and I think you
can agree dirt where there's a ceiling
right obviously you do the drama stuff
you might hit up quicker but you're
gonna hit the ceiling faster because
your audience and demographic it expands
depending on what you do if you do
gaming there's a there's a ceiling for
any gaming YouTube channel right because
there's only certain amount of people on
YouTube that watch gaming related
content perfect but then when you do
let's say drama you know talking about
this person said that that person said
this and that's the only kind of video
you make okay you're in the gaming one
which you have a ceiling but then you
lower that selling because only a
certain amount of those gamers are with
that kind of content and then it goes
down so forth and so forth but when you
if you cover gaming it's really hard to
grow YouTube channel without being in
some form of a toxic environment yeah
it's almost impossible I'm gonna be real
with you guys because a lot of people
especially in our community uh you know
if they're not see there's a difference
between doing console related stuff and
taking it to out of context like if the
only content you have is other people
and what they say and you're trying to
raise your stuff
that is way worse than just making fun
of Fanboys that say stuff and it's just
like you know
I know I do it a lot you know I might
I'm like I I backflip into the into the
pool of toxicity and I don't mind doing
it because I know at the end of the day
it's just jokes and entertainment it's
nothing serious I know these people
aren't stopping me from sleeping I
regardless what someone says on Twitter
I might not agree with them but it's not
taking me past that point I don't care
what some of these people on Twitter
said I might scroll past and say this is
an idiot most of the time I won't even
comment and what's funny is because you
know I try to keep the peace I have
people that I follow
that I can't unfollow
because it will start issues oh I got
you so I mute them
I got you so it's just like look like
that's my advice to you guys if you're
wanting to start a YouTube channel and
you're curious on how to grow once you
feel like you've hit a certain Peak go
to these events man you know it might
cost you a couple Grand sometimes
depending on where you're going you know
if you're around like the Boston area
and you want to go to packs that might
not cost you much of anything just the
tickets and the gas and that's all maybe
a day off of work if you if you can get
that day off you won't even have to do
that but you'd be surprised on having
content when the actual content drops is
so
important and that's that's why I've
always been very vocal about you can
only grow so far without the industry
helping you grow do you think IGN will
be where it is without
people sending them review copies people
giving them interviews no they wouldn't
and you got to get yourself to a point
where you can get some of that access to
help you elevate yourself above other
people that don't have that access
yep
we went on a complete side step I
apologize for that uh I don't know what
happened you know we're gonna go and
move on to the Halo thing because I know
that's what a lot of you guys are here
for now they're probably let's be real
here they're here for these PlayStation
topics
all right sorry I'm still out of the
weather so if I'm coughing and well I'm
I'm you my mic and also stop my camera
if I gotta you know like blow my nose or
something oh you're fine man so you know
I'm putting the time stamp off here it's
in here for 36 minutes and 50 seconds I
got you guys don't come get me man it's
in there all right so let's talk about
this Halo rumor it does look like
it's highly remembered and when I say
highly rumored uh you know I'm not gonna
get myself in trouble all right so all
I'm saying and all I'll say about this
has been rumored that it looks like 343
might be moving on with a different
Engine with the Unreal Engine that looks
like they might be uh throwing away the
slip space engine and another thing
that's going around is they might be
abandoning the Halo infinite IP uh so
we're gonna go one by one by dirt what
do you think about the Unreal Engine
being implemented and being rebuilt
for hey well um
if this rumor is true I'm listening I'm
not a game developer obviously so
whatever
makes the team that 343 comfortable
do it all right let's do it you know um
yeah it's true
it's true 100 it's true okay okay so
okay so with that being said um
if there's something they feel excuse me
I'm sorry
if this is something they feel they have
to do
damn it I'm sorry bro oh you're fine man
I think I got covered um
if this is something they feel they have
to do to make the game better now the
gameplay
solid bro solid game play I even enjoyed
the campaign I enjoyed it but if
slip space is causing issues to where
they can't produce the amount of content
that they want to in the time that they
want to if slip space is causing
stuff to where it's disrupting
development
hey man you know they had to do what
they had to do so at the end of the day
I'm I'm fine with it I just want Halo
well now I didn't hear about you saying
they're like missing I mean like letting
go of the IP itself oh well that's the
room with the rumor was and I I have
heard from multiple sources that this is
happening it's not like it's not rumor
even Jazz Corden came out on Twitter
what's funny is just Gordon eventually
came out and said this is lies
uh but then the next morning I guess
after he he asked a couple more info
yeah he retracted that statement uh and
I've heard similar things uh for
multiple people and it's just like look
like
I think we all know that Halo infinite
could be could be saved but that name's
already tainted
and I think people know that the best
way to engage more interest into a Halo
France franchise at this moment is to
just make a new Halo game
well I mean yes and no I think Halo
infinite can be okay once they
get the content rolling in on a
consistent basis like bone slave said in
the chat he said they don't need to
switch engines they just need to give us
content I think that's part of the issue
slip space is causing difficulties now
I'm assuming this here
but why else would they want to change
engines if it was giving them some
issues
um when you look at cyberpunk right at
it you have to say cyberpunk was looking
bro that game was killed even made CD
probably red look like hey man I thought
you guys were Geniuses what is this mess
now you see when they you know with a
little time they fixed it I know the
Netflix show helped also but people went
back to the game and now you're sitting
there breaking all types of records for
CD project red people streaming it the
sales went up crazy so I think
just my personal opinion I don't think
the name Halo infinite
um
can't be repaired I think it can with
the content for if horse mode just
becomes the absolute hit without
expected to be with the creativity of
some of these Gamers out here
but with them switching the engine good
I mean that's what they want to do
that's what they're comfortable with
that's going to benefit them as a studio
I'm all for it man I'm all for it like
who am I to say what are y'all doing no
don't do that no no I'm all for it
because I'ma say it one more time you
know before you go
there must be something with that slip
space engine that has been causing
causing issues flat out yeah and you
know talking about cyberpunk briefly I I
think one of the biggest reasons of
cyberpunk has resurged so much doesn't
have to do with the TV show now I think
the TV show gains interest but I think
people will see oh yo that TV show Good
let me go back and try the game because
I can guarantee you that a lot of these
people that went back and tried the game
already owned the damn thing right so
it's just like they're always cyberpunk
their money it's just right you know
they're playing the game in this in the
the state that really it should have
been in from the start uh look you know
you can give a lot of that to the TV
show because at least it gained interest
but you have to have a product to be
able to actually do that cyberpunk
was really bad when it launched but it
was never a bad product it just didn't
run correctly
so it is what it is I think when it
comes to the Halo thing
I think you're gonna the reason that
that they're getting rid of what they're
doing is not necessarily because of they
feel like a little infinite is not
savable because I agree with you give
them content people are going to come
but I think their mindset is if we're
gonna rebuild the game we might as well
just drop it because then they would
have to rebuild Halo infinite and I
think their mindsets like look well
we'll keep supporting Halo infinite for
a while
while we build this other game and then
when this other game launches it's going
to be a new engine and at that point are
we going to keep Halo infinite going
in the slip space and keep Halo Halo
endless going I see what you're saying
now that makes sense now that makes a
lot of sense yes still support Halo
infinite while you're building this
other Unreal Engine Halo campaign
multiplayer then yeah this yeah I see
what you're saying now that makes sense
that definitely makes sense yeah and
it's just like
look
I do think that it's it's convenient
first off Jess Gordon didn't know about
this at first Jess Gordon has his ear to
the ground at all times this dude knows
a lot of stuff I know certain things
that he knows because I'm pretty sure
some people we have is the same source
and it's crazy this man ain't come out
and said this the stuff that jazz cord
knows would blow the damn internet up
but he I respect it man because just
chord it looks like he operates like
this he walks around with all this
knowledge but he only leaks the stuff he
knows someone else is about to leak
right because at the end of the day
that's his job like he gets paid off of
how much traffic he brings to the
website and if he knows a juicy amount
of information to buy to get leaked you
would be dumb not to do it yourself
first
so and what's funny is
he knows a lot more than people think
about some of these unreleased uh Xbox
games uh he knows a lot more than I do I
know there are certain things I still
don't know that he knows but it's just
like it's it's crazy it's crazy so I
think you guys gonna be excited about
the future of Xbox like and you know we
ain't going too much into that yeah yeah
but you know hey hey Halo infinite if
this makes Halo infinite better I'm all
for it I just want the franchise to be
where it used to be I'm personally in
the in the mindset I don't think it's
ever going to be
what it was a long time ago because I
don't think it had the competition it
has now uh the day where you can have a
fortnight Apex Legends and you know war
zone are constantly fighting for that
top three spot now you got stuff like
Fall Guys appearing out of nowhere
getting a lot of traffic I don't it's
going to be really hard to compete with
these games it's gonna be right
absolutely and you know what that kind
of reminds me of um when G4 came back
G4 could never be what they were before
because this is a different time there's
too much competition out here right
um and when you say Halo bro listen I
told a story on my channel several times
where I was at a midnight launch for
Halo 3 nothing
yeah my I have experienced my 46 years
gaming wise
will
Eclipse that that midnight launch
because I was working part-time for game
uh stop uh and it was just the most
crazy experience ever man the lines
around the corner we use this small Game
Stop
lying around the corner people was it's
hyped for Halo 3 man uh I couldn't
believe it I was like damn so it will
never get to those Heights that it was
but I still believe Halo can be a solid
franchise and people still like the
franchise man they just gotta you know
to get everything good yeah and it's
just like one of those one of those
things where I just the Halo brand has
took such a hit
that I'm just
I want it to be back where it is and if
this engine is resulting in the majority
of these issues and I do think it is I
think the reason you're not seeing the
content in the way that you want to is
because it's almost impossible to get
the content out that you guys want on
this engine it's kind of crazy to me
that Xbox decide you know what let's
make a new engine and have our Flagship
title on it out the gate they should
have did what coalitions doing now make
a game in an Unreal Engine 5 that's not
gear six and then make gear six when
they feel more comfortable with that
franchise right
so we got a little bit of super chats
here got two dollars from flame time to
take Halo infinite out back like oh
Hollow oh my god look man oh yellow we
we are not killing Halo infinite we got
a fight show some respect no oh did you
see his piece that he made this morning
who his article the flame that article
is burning the internet alive oh no no
let me read you let me just read you the
uh
the all right let me find it let me read
you just what what it says
opinion piece PlayStation's become a
creativity bankrupt I did see I didn't
read the article though oh okay so
that's flame I didn't really realize who
flame was okay yeah that's flame hey hey
how you doing buddy I apologize hey hey
you you got to say you gotta you gotta
say Coke voice man you gotta say close
voice hey sucker my bad
five dollar Super Chat for the angry
therapist MD uh shout out to Dirk why
wouldn't Xbox use the Doom in tech
engine all right so just to clarify uh
MJ are you talking about Halo being made
in the in the tech engine what's that
engine called the ID
um the itch software engine what's that
engine called
I don't know I don't know I don't know
bro all I know is that the ID engine I
don't know and I think that's what it is
okay so Intec
here's the thing
I think that
I don't want Halo to be that fast I
don't think people understand how fast
of a game dude really is dude is man let
me tell you something when I play Doom
2016 I I hated it at first I was like
this game is too damn fast I put it down
for like two years bro picked it back up
fell in love with it was like oh what
was I thinking but it meant no way no no
that game was too fast the engine is
built though but I don't think that
engine fits Halo just in my opinion I
think they need to just work on Quake
like rumor if they're working on a quake
I think that's the best game they need
to work on you know who I would actually
like to make a single player again I've
said this all uh before I don't know if
I've ever talked to you about it I would
like
uh you know 343 I think is one of the
only Studios that can work on the
multiplayer at this point uh but I do
think that maybe the single player can
be tossed to someone else and I think
the perfect Studio to make that game and
I know you guys are going to disagree
with me because you make this very clear
every time I say this this opinion is I
honestly feel like a good Studio to make
a single player experience for Halo
would be machine games like they did
with Wolfenstein
oh well listen listen let me tell you
this
I love the Wolfenstein games with the
exception of that
bloodborne whatever that was blood what
is it blood I don't know
trash it was trash
listen there's something there but I'ma
tell you bro I love Halo Infinity
campaign I loved it the like the grapple
hook was a game changer I love the
champagne what I like some more biomes
absolutely uh but I think that will come
so the multiplayer is fire I'm sorry
the Halo infinite to me is a great game
just need more content I think so the
reason I disagree a little bit on the
single play I like the single player but
I want this I want Halo single player to
be immersive and look like I do feel
like seeing it's a fun sandbox but I
don't think hail infinite's a very
immersive game like when you play like
machine gun uh machine games you're
playing Wolfenstein oh those games are
dope and you're literally you're
shooting people in a wheelchair rolling
yourself down a hallway that's an
immersive experience
and that's what I want from Halo and
obviously I don't want them to put like
Nazis and stuff in Halo that'd be weird
uh but you know I do feel a lot of tell
you add it Doom Reaper has a great point
doing Reaper says machine games have
their own damn games to make attic and
this is this is a conversation about who
would make what and what would make you
know what you know what we're gonna do
next week well you know what we gonna do
next week sir I saw unless something big
happens next week which is this is the
time where stuff little calms down a
little bit
um I saw hey I saw over there a defining
Duke ultimate do a draft a fantasy draft
for Xbox games we're gonna do that next
week okay we're gonna do that next week
because I think that sounds fun now I
gotta sound fun I'm gonna re-watch it to
make sure I snatch they they they outlay
perfectly and I want to gobble that up
be obviously I'm gonna add fire it but
you know I got that I like the concepts
yeah I'm not identify it but I like the
concept of that so that's probably what
we're doing next week unless something
crazy happens this week which I don't I
don't know I don't see that happening I
don't know things just been really crazy
in General lately but you know I think
that's the where I stand it's like I
don't mind at three four three I've
always said that in terms of a single
player and a multiplayer game combined
the only Studio that can make that three
four three
like no one can take away the fact that
Halo is expected to be fantastic in both
multiplayer and single player a lot of
multi a lot of first-person shooters
these days don't have that expectation
on their ass they only got really one or
the other look some people might like
the the campaign for Call of Duty but
it's it's
it's the exception not the rule like
there's not a lot of them most people
when they buy Call of Duty they're
thinking of that multiplayer uh
Maddie thought the Dead Space would get
delayed but with the pre-orders going
out I think we will miss his predictions
for Dead Space yeah it is what it is you
know we we'll go and move on with that
we I think we need a little bit more
information in terms of that we need to
see exactly what's going on now the
question I would have to you real quick
before we move on is that they do do
this and they do switch engines you
think they'll be very transparent with
their you think they won't tell us until
the game is pretty much done
oh I'm thinking they will be transparent
but the question is when will they be
transparent I can just imagine them
doing doing one little small YouTube
videos saying how they switch engines um
but I think they will probably let us
know a couple years into development I
don't see him doing it now
yeah unless they were there unless
they're delaying some stuff some some
some uh future you know DLC if they're
delaying some future content then they
might go we're you know unfortunately we
have to switch engines and blah blah
blah so hopefully that's not the case
you know when I would see them doing it
when was that the BR is officially
announced hmm I think they might hit you
with two announcements show you the BR
and then say we got one more thing to
show you and it's it's Halo endless
because it's been rumored for a while
that the story portion of the game was
being delayed of 2024 and people thought
what is going on well yeah and it turns
out that that was true it looks like and
the reason it was delayed to 2024 is
because they remaking they're making it
in a different engine so you know it is
we're going to see what happens there
I'm very curious uh we'll we'll
definitely be talking about this again
in the future uh but you know let's
let's talk about everyone's foot you
know this was one of King's favorite
topics the other day man uh stadia is
going down in flames and I don't think
anyone should be very surprised the
steady is going down in flames uh so I
did hit I hit up those time steps man 54
minutes and 45 seconds so Mafia but you
know the time step Mafia you have been
served you got your uh you got your time
for me so stadia it's
it's going down in flames and I don't
think anyone really expected anything
different to be honest oh hell no now
there are some people okay okay
so what was the justifications that you
saw them use
well there's one guy in particular he
pretty much said uh this wasn't expected
um he didn't see this coming
I didn't listen to it long enough to
hear why he didn't see it coming I just
was laughing so hard I just cut it off
um I don't know man after this this is
pretty obvious to me
they wanted to try to squeeze into the
gaming industry
they like they were trying to sell a
stadium with the technology I heard that
technology was very good
but you need more than technology
imagine the original Xbox them trying to
sell the original Xbox well hey we have
a hard drive inside of the console yeah
I'm gonna be like okay what about what
games do you have sir so they tried to
sell the stadium with it's technology
yeah it's just so you know install
needed okay but what games am I in
playing bro
they had first party then they got rid
of first party
I just don't understand they did not
want to compete because when they heard
Xbox bought
um zenimax for 7.5 billion they was like
whoa whoa oh wait a minute
hold on
hey he turned the coke oh you hell no
you jive turkey I gotta spend 7.5
billions Hells and all millions of a
Beats
billions with a B sucker hell's not not
so they was like nah man we we're not
trying to compete like that it's just I
don't know but you can't be coming to
the gaming business Frugal like you
don't want to spend your money
but they did sign all those third-party
games spending 40 50 million on Red Dead
Redemption 2 and Destiny 2 and bro but
those games are everywhere you why would
I invest into Stadium give me a reason
and I need more than the technology is
great
give me something what first part of the
game y'all had a code nope didn't didn't
want to invest with him so it's like
crazy man I'm like come on bro I think
the problem with stadium is they didn't
take the industry seriously they felt
like they could walk in and kick the
door open and say we got money and just
throw out like fat stacks everywhere and
it doesn't work that way like their best
bet to come in is they should have came
in uh a couple years prior and they
should have worked with these second
party people that actually had a a
household name to a point but that would
have been a great Studio a company to
work with and say yo what's it gonna
take to get Starfield on our platform a
couple months earlier what's it going to
take to get the you know Wolfenstein 3
that's up a couple months earlier What's
it gonna take to get death Loop in that
a couple months early they don't even
need like full-blown exclusive they
would have just came in and got like a
60-day timed exclusive sure you might
not got everybody I don't think you
would have got everybody but you know
what I would have thought you you would
have got you would have got users and
then you start branching out to your own
first party and this is just stuff that
you use to get the ball rolling it's not
what you use at the end and I think that
was the biggest thing they they just
didn't take it seriously they thought
they could just come in here and just
say yo we got ex we got technology he
use it yeah and what's funny is a lot of
the stuff that they show didn't even
work bro
I thought the YouTube thing where you
can watch a trailer and it will say play
then you can click play I thought that
was fire I was like yo that would be
dope it never happened you know it was
it was so fire it was lying
right it was like man and the crazy part
because of this
they've probably I don't know how you
feel about this Dart but I feel like
because of this
they're done in gaming I I don't think
the consumer's ever going to trust them
again they can come out there off a
console next year and unless they take
it seriously and they show commitment no
one's going to do anything with that
player absolutely I agree they're
they're done again I agree with you bro
the only thing I could see oh if someone
uses the um the attack if they lease out
the tech to it to someone that's the
only way I could see them still
remaining in gaming but they're
absolutely done bro like you say
nobody's gonna touch them
while I'm seeing on Twitter right now
you know uh kind of like breaking news
not really like anything serious it's
kind of crazy that it looks like
OverWatch 2 is restricting people on
prepaid phones from doing the uh the
two-way verification thing so if you
want to play OverWatch 2 and you got a
prepaid phone which is I think a lot of
people a lot of people don't trust the
cell phone providers because they like
to give you hit you with hidden hidden
uh
hidden prices all the time if you got if
you got that you know you got that
straight talk they're gonna look at you
and say come back with acnt yeah that's
crazy wow
that's what I'm seeing on Twitter yeah
it might not be true uh you know how
Twitter is but ACG reported it so I
doubt it's not true ACG usually pretty
accurate before he starts making uh
tweets about anything it's just like you
know we'll go ahead and move on to the
uh the PlayStation Stars it's sad the
degree that corporations decide like it
really is it's sad and especially you
saw it with stadia stadia saw the money
that was to be made in gaming but didn't
look why gamers are Gamers they thought
they could come in there and just say yo
we got games and sure they did go out
and they got some first party stuff I
can understand shutting down Stadium I
feel like they should have at least gave
their first party stuff Studios that the
ones that they did have at least enough
time to make a game and then beforehand
you're right and then okay you know this
ain't working we're not seeing the the
profit margins let's go ahead and uh and
cancel this but they didn't they
abandoned [ __ ] like way too soon
because they it's like they they like
told their first Friday teams hey start
developing games now nobody bro they
should have been developing games two
years prior to your release you know
you're absolutely right about that yeah
it's ridiculous oh your favorite uh
person in the world Dawn the taco with
the five dollar Super Chat talk about
the biggest news in gaming
dirt because I'm Gonna Save dirt in
there because you know he's talking to
you this week you cowards okay so he's
talking to me okay I I see you they took
away Mario's in the Super Mario movie
poster we need more awareness so you you
want to see another grown man's behind
is that what you telling me Donna taku I
I'm gonna have you hold up
Donald talk usually don't Super Chat and
troll so I'm really I get you know look
if if you roll that way
100 supportive but I don't want to see
another man's behind that's just me
though
Mario kids game uh I mean no Donna talk
who thinks that that that
um
that switch is life man that's like the
greatest life you know he didn't he say
that uh Splatoon was better than uh Halo
yeah he said it was bad in the Halo
gears Cod everything Hey look it's
enforcer hey look Jason
he's uh a very interesting person he he
always brings yeah I actually I don't
know if it's a he or she I'm pretty sure
it's a he maybe maybe I don't know maybe
it is a she I don't we can't really
verify whether or not who's what gender
uh but it's just like look like
the chat makes a lot of these topics
better you know uh I'm pretty sure Donna
talk is going to be on us eventually in
this podcast so let's move on before he
he had a super huh
oh flame two dollar Super Chat it's true
blizzard said don't y'all have phones
oh my God man no burner phones no phones
from The Wire this you better yeah at
this point man if
if you do an illegal activity you have a
phone for illegal activities
uh you can't play OverWatch that's crazy
that is absurd imagine what it's like to
to to to to support a developer well I
actually download a free to play game
but once if you actually have money and
what's funny is some of these I know
that at the end of the day I don't think
these people carry these money come from
and some of these people doing these uh
the these burner phones they got they
got they got plenty of money to burn
through for no reason you would actually
want them spending money on your game
because they ain't gonna they dude I
know people that could have dropped a
dropped three or four hundred dollars
like what like it was nothing they had
some of these uh some of these burner
phones but you know oh it's we gotta
find all the Superstar from John Wolf
John Wolf uh Google and Sony working
together as a tag team trying to block
the deal highly uh suspects so
suspicious shout out to dirt Natick
let's talk about that you know
yeah this is we're not moving on yet I
gotta talk about this
oh yeah it is convenient right that what
that both of them are are answering they
open up their mouth this close to this
happening like where was where was
Stadium when they first bought them they
you know Jim Ryan's been snitching this
whole time so I kind of expected from
him but what was Jim Ryan at that point
five dollar subject from King Metro
train I had Straight Talk for years and
had no problems they did it to stop
Smurf accounts
uh yeah but here's the thing
maybe there's just maybe
part of me understands that King but the
other part of me is like if they're not
letting prepaid
plans do the two-way verification
they are limiting themselves to so many
people I know a lot of people that don't
have like a big carrier and what's funny
is straight talking all them
they just use other people's Towers
so it's just like there's not there's a
difference it is what it is I I get that
uh you know but let's let's go back to
this smoke you know
where was what's what's this uh uh Phil
Harrison Phil Harrison Man actually I
don't feel here yeah
King has asked us to call him Mr
Harrison he he doesn't deserve to have
the fill part of his name
just take away the Phi but keep the l l
here
so so Al Harrison
kept his mouth shut this whole time well
actually they didn't he actually said
for in the the Brazil documents that he
had no problem with it
oh so I don't know if you remember in
the Brazil documents Phil Harris in the
stadium whoever said they had no problem
with the activism but there's an Xbox
deal did you have no problem with it did
you see that Jim Ryan like went to I
think it was like uh London or UK or
somewhere there Brussels yeah and talk
to them personally oh my God
like the
the extent this man is doing to stop
this deal
it's like that that dude that never gets
over the X that's constantly like every
adding her on on on Facebook and stuff
it it's crazy to me how are you gonna
You're Gonna Fly yourself to another
country and and and plead to them plead
to them don't let them buy this that's
the money that was my money
bro this is sad man think about it when
we heard he flew to Brussels he wanted
to talk to him face to face
to face like little bloody blocked this
deal you know I just blocked the bloody
deal bro this is the CEO of a
PlayStation or whatever his damn title
is
he's up there looking weak he's looking
vulnerable he's looking like a straight
up punk you know what's funny bro what's
it it's like after that after they say
no we got an Xbox series X at the back
man we are we already made our decisions
up Jim's like he's like he's like
texting his assistant stop the stakes
from coming here
no what the hell are you bright doing
over here no yeah I just can't believe
it man I just don't understand
how the number of one to two because
sometimes they draw back to two most
profitable company in gaming is sitting
here saying like it's like winning the
race and complaining because four is
still back at four
like it's like maybe you know what I
guess a better analogy would be like the
reason PlayStation is winning the race
to that degree is uh is because like
they're secretly riding a bicycle
halfway through the race and Microsoft's
trying to buy the manufacturer of the
bicycle so they can ride the bicycle and
they're pissed like no you can't take
this bicycle away my money that's my
money well you know Jim Ryan has always
been he's a very money driven person he
doesn't care about your exclusives he'll
put those suckers on mobile if he'll
make money off of that but
losing Cod and not necessarily like you
know they have that three-year deal so
four years from uh from this year on the
card expansion and they we don't know
where it's going to go after that and
and I think we can all agree that for
the most part
that is going to stay on Playstation
there's a good chat I don't know maybe
after you know you know because Jim Jim
be snitching bad you know and I'm pretty
sure if I was Phil Spencer and I'm
sitting here and I made this all this
stuff like yo we'll keep it on there for
three years after next year that's four
years Jim Ryan we've given you plenty of
time to make a counter attack you know
we've given you plenty of time to find
someone else to sit in that ring with
Call of Duty and instead of Jim Ryan say
yo I appreciate it Phil yo get everyone
together we got to make a game he like
can we have more line can we have more
time
imagine being the other Studios and
saying yo
they literally can't make someone he's
saying that we ain't competent to make
someone to compete with that colossal
and look like they might be able to make
something that the quality is there but
they'll never make something that
replicates the Call of Duty name right
right
ever right game gamer by choice to the
two dollar Super Chat the Google
PlayStation coming soon great show
Google PlayStation yo what they look
have we seen that Google can't make
decisions so if they teamed up I would
you know you know who I would be a
little nervous if they teamed up with
PlayStation or they bought Apple
PlayStation no Disney
oh oh hell yeah you do you think nervous
about that all the IP they own hell no
yo Disney about Disney about to make yo
Disney's the only people that could come
out there
Disney's the only people that could come
out there
and they can make
exclusives back to back and do a
Nintendo thing yeah
I would be scared of Disney Infinity
I'll be scared of that Kingdom Hearts
exclusive all the comic book stuff
exclusive exclusive yeah they make a
Frozen game for the little kids
exclusive my goodness
yeah that'll be that'll be rough right
there see look we don't care if Google
teams up with PlayStation we do care if
Disney teams up with PlayStation right
because what if you think about whatever
Disney has wanted they have got there's
been no offense butts about it they
wanted Fox they got Fox they wanted Fox
for one reason and that's for Marvel
imagine walking into a building and
buying something for three people on the
top floor
hmm
and then you walk out and they're like
yo we're the only ones beneficial here
they got what they wanted they out of
the building what's gonna happen to us
now you're right they got everything
they want except for
the rise of Spider-Man fully but besides
that the Spider-Man movie right but they
still got what they wanted using
Spiderman and what's funny is is
Sony tried to walk walk take their ball
and walk home with the the uh when the
they didn't make an agreement on it and
the funny thing is they still got what
they want
they're like oh you could go home you
know people are gonna be mad at us
because we making Marvel but we still
got plenty of Marvel people it's not
Spider-Man we'll still survive it's like
but are you guys gonna survive right
it's so you ain't got nobody but
Spiderman so they just walking home look
at looking at their money and they're
like we got plenty of money from that
last Spider-Man and they get home and
then they realize but how much of this
can we keep right and then they realize
like they just released what was the
name of that Jared Leto um I can't think
of it what's the name of the movie with
Jared with Jared Leto I can't pick it up
um The Joker thing no no the the the
Jared Leto movie it was very bad
um Morpheus Morpheus yes we got more oh
damn we know we got it no you know let's
call it Disney boy morbius is the only
movie in history that got me to death so
they thought bringing the movie back to
the movies after the memes would help
the cells facts the only movie ever
imagine the only relying chance you have
of having a successful brand is using
memes to your advantage it's on Netflix
now I'm actually give it a chance
it's on Netflix did that movie come out
like six months ago it's on Netflix
that might as well went straight to DVD
we got five dollars to drive for Conway
PS and Amazon will be a threat uh I
don't know about that but PS with Amazon
money and Technology would be a dominant
Force especially once Studio already has
solid student once Sony already since so
since Sony already has solid Studios I
agree with that but I don't think Amazon
knows what the hell they do in half the
time either look at look at the the
state of twitch
like see here's the thing PlayStation
will budge a little bit off social
economic stuff that's going on social
trends social stuff going on where you
know they're they're too afraid to put
someone in in a situation or anything
like that uh you know you see it with
stuff like God of War where they took
like a lot of the blood and violence out
of God of War where you're not really
killing human human uh like people
anymore it's like mainly monsters and
stuff like God of War Three you killed
oh my God you killed um brutal man uh
you killed uh Poseidon for like 15
minutes like
you're not kiddies oh my God you're not
getting that but if Amazon owns Sony I
don't even think you would see you would
see even that type of violence I think
they would they would make them pull
back even more because Amazon has no
problem they have no problem you know
pushing the the brakes on something when
they think it's gonna hurt them social
wise
hunt
yeah
yeah I got you man um
all right so let's go and move on we
definitely went on a side tangent there
let's talk about PlayStation Stars yeah
this is a funny conversation man this is
I'm gonna let you get your balls off
first man every PlayStation conversation
has been funny the last four or five
months every every week There's been
something everywhere every week
all right so go and get your bars off
man
PlayStation Stars where do I start bro
where do I start with PlayStation stars
um honestly I don't know much about it
all I know is
all I know is that if you buy four full
price games get 123 rare trophies
you will get the great incentive of
customer priority that mean when you
have to call Sony say look man my PS5 is
messing up
they say oh
you're level four let me put you right
at the front of the line so instead of
waiting for 45 minutes you got to wait
10 minutes congratulations
congratulations that's such a great
incentive and you know the funny thing
they didn't say they're going to get a
better experience they're just going to
get a quicker experience you're going to
wait in line for 10 minutes and I had to
wait in line for 40. and you're still
going to get the same dumb experience
that I got waiting for four and you got
for 10. sure you might be out of there
sooner uh but it's just funny that
they're going through this extreme to
make you know the PlayStation start why
don't you just give discounts on stuff
do what everyone else does I saw that
somebody posted because it's I guess it
officially started today
and somebody posted some stuff about
um don't quote me on this but I think I
read something that
if you buy a full price game you only
get 50 points
oh
like something like I said don't quote
me on this
uh regardless even if it's 50 points
this is like
I think that
it's okay here there's a couple other
people that do it you know we Sam's Club
has an exclusive thing I think Costco
does too you can't even walk into Sam's
Club unless you buy their uh by their
year pass like they have someone at the
front door let's just let me show you
let me see your ticket let me see your
ticket
you don't got the ticket you gotta be a
member you gotta be a member yeah yeah
you don't you got you don't got the
ticket they telling you to turn around
and leave so
um I'm sorry not to control but breaking
news but it's well kind of breaking news
um so far is Brazil has approved the
acquisition activism blizzard with no
restrictions Brazil has approved it so
that's just one step in the right
direction just want to let you know
I think it's getting approved like 100
getting approved with zero restrictions
this year that's the first step that's
the first step let's go baby yeah it is
what it is when it comes to that you
know this PlayStation star thing is just
crazy it's crazy to think about doing
it's crazy that you're going to lock
down a better customer service in terms
of how fast you get served behind just
playing and and I was doing the research
thing I don't know if it's full retail
games or anything like that uh but you
have to have like how many I how many um
[Music]
um
what's what I'm looking for how many
um
how many trophies do you need it's like
219 or something
um I thought it said 193. that's still a
lot though yeah and uh four full price
games to be level four Sir Mr added
you're a level four you've been to the
front of the line when they say full
full price games do they mean like not
games that's not on sale or they have to
be 70 retail price I'm sorry you said
128. railski says 128. is it any trophy
or just a specific trophy is that rare
trophies
so I mean that's not too bad but still
that yeah that's crazy man yeah that it
is what it is look like you're going to
get a little bit of reward if you go
ahead and go through with this and play
more games which I'm always down for
people playing games I I don't I feel
like they should just offer better
extent it was like you know because
first off how often are you gonna really
call
customer service anyway if you're
calling customer service a lot you're
for a bad platform exactly bro exactly I
mean you might not never have to call
customer service I've you know the last
time I had to call Xbox customer service
was when the red rings are definitely no
seven that's literally the last time I
had to call customer service for Xbox
it is what it is
foreign
that's the last time
and that's 2007. I I I I've tried to
call them a couple times for refunds and
they never do it ever like ever do it uh
it is what it is they've always been
very vocal about being uh you know
serious on stuff like that so I mean
go ahead and keep talking I gotta handle
stuff okay I got you bro yeah so um
PlayStation stars is funny right uh hey
look man you know some people love it
we're just gonna laugh at it listen it's
it's a it's a
incentive based program I listen I love
Xbox Rewards I don't check it every time
but I know when I purchase games and
then when I will occasionally check it I
might see twenty thirty dollars Mike I
put it right on my account
um I'm not sure how much money you get
off a PlayStation Stars
but I'm like what the hell
I'm feeling a little better man like I
said I think I got covered again
I had got tested last week it was um
negative but uh so like after that I
start getting the symptoms again
BS you know but I'm feeling better
though
um yeah guys so how do you guys feel
about everything man because PlayStation
stars look I'm not a hater some people
think I hate PlayStation I don't hate
PlayStation
I hate ponies but
it was I think it's just interesting man
interesting stuff and this is what it is
I you know they are it's their opinion
that they should give stuff in the in
the way they do if they should give any
type of form of incentive to do anything
I feel like there's better things they
could have done that doesn't involve
what they did but it's not my job to do
it uh you know in fact and and I do
think it's it's very interesting that
not many people called them out on it
really like you know you might have had
like a couple hours where people said
this is this is dumb but then it went
away no one's talking about it now and
you know what else now I'm talking about
how they ain't having no showcases
nobody's talking about that either
either addict how they're not having
this showcase this year but yeah you're
right you know I don't want to be messy
I'm sorry bro oh no it's true remember
we was talking like three or four months
ago that I said I don't think they're
having a showcase this year you you said
it I don't think it was that long it
might have been three or four weeks ago
when you said I don't think they're
having a showcase and I said if they
don't announce something within the next
couple weeks they're not and they
announced the state of play
that was just like pretty much the the
Tokyo game show state of play that
wasn't even like their full-blown state
of play and then people banned like
people were saying no there's no other
one there's another one I'm like dude
they announced they're Ronin they
announced another IP and they showed you
God of War gameplay that was your stay
to play this year
that was a showcase you mean yeah that
was a showcase bro because that's what I
meant that was your showcase this year
yeah that was a showcase exactly man
because they those two games being
exclusive I think those are showcase
worthy announcements and some more God
of War gameplay hey that's showcase
stuff because God Awards that game but
they didn't the the crazy part is they
didn't feel comfortable coming out and
showing it is a showcase
um like they're like we got we gonna
we're gonna say it's a state of play
um We're not gonna come out here and say
that this is the biggest content we have
for here and what's funny is uh I I beat
Valkyrie Elysium
um I beat that game and what's it
getting right now on metacrity it's low
man it's it look I'm not saying this
game was a bad game
but what's funny it's a 66 right now on
Metacritic uh what's funny is it's an
exclusive game for PlayStation 5.
but when something happens and Xbox gets
a bad game that they didn't even publish
or make and people love to put that up
on the front center like that's all
that's fire yeah that's all right that's
all that content and then people don't
bring up the Val the valkyrie leasing
games like the game was a very blad game
it's got a great gameplay like gameplay
alone I feel like is really good and if
I was a really if I was if I didn't have
nothing to play I might pay 60 70 bucks
just for the gameplay just because
that's how bored it's been this this
past month but it's just like you know
we're coming up on
a lot of games coming out we have uh
Dead Space which was just recently
announced for a 70-day 70 title uh
coming out in I think March we got
Callisto protocol coming out in December
we have God of War coming out next month
like
we eating good right now yeah yeah the
next is the protocol yeah the games look
great the net Babylon Falls they have a
lot of flaws if you actually really sit
down and think about it so Sony funds a
lot of flops like yeah they do and it's
just like sometimes I just want to be in
the room when they when when they're
going over this game and the content and
with the actual final product is going
to be and just be like
how do you think this is going to be it
right like like when someone looks at
something like you know cyberpunk coming
out as busted as it was how did the
boardroom say people won't love this you
know you know forget a game working
correctly you know what we want we want
to keep you in that game you know how
we're going to keep you in that game
making you play the same five minutes
over and over again like it's just
I think that's why I'm I'm on this big
thing it's like look if your game is
busted I feel like you should get yanked
off every platform you shouldn't have an
option to sell your game and I think you
know Sony did it for their own reasons
but I I 100 agreed with Sony when they
did it because they're like look like
we're having all these people refund
your game so we're just gonna pull your
game off our platform and I I feel like
if everyone would have that same energy
when a game comes out broken there would
be no more broken games
like sure it would take a little bit and
then we have to like kind of dissect
what is a broken game and what's a buggy
game because I feel like those can come
a little bit too close to each other you
know a broken game is a lot of key
variables that's game breaking that
prevents you from playing the game and a
buggy game just gets you annoyed that's
all I think that's the difference with
the two yeah
I agree with you brother
all right so let's listen
yeah let's let's talk about Horizon zero
Dawn oh snap getting a remake rumor
rumor but I think I think at this point
man
it's it's not a rumor like this sucker
about to come out again what two three
years after it came out the first time
no probably about four four years after
that's five it's five years because it
came out of 2017. that's still bad
though like it is bro
what's funny is I understood last of us
I still don't agree with the the
practice they used to do it so okay they
want to Rebrand last of us because they
made a Last of Us Part Two they want to
make a Last of Us Part One so when they
do blast of Us Part three they kind of
go together you know last episode one
two and three but there is no logical
reason that I can think of to have a
horizon zero Dawn remake you know dirt
tell me what you think man tell me what
you think
I can't think of one reason
this game should have a remake like you
just said I can't think of a reason bro
like why like the game still is monetary
value
I guess
like the game still looks beautiful
beautiful right this game should just be
uh PS5 upgrade 4K 60.
is it already upgraded for the PS5 I
don't even know
right I don't even know if it's already
upgraded for the PS5 this is suspect I
don't understand
I understand this is a new PlayStation
this is the new regime they're doing
things different but this makes
absolutely no sense whatsoever
no sense this isn't an old game like
dead space or you know Resident Evil 4.
this game came out in 2017. Hell the
sequel just came out this year
I don't get it bro I only have much to
say about this but I'm sure some
PlayStation Fanboys love it
good thing though all right so
my issue with this whole thing
is are they doing it to make money or
are they doing it because they people
have ran out of ideals like like it's
crazy like instead of having naughty dog
work on the Last of Us Part three
they're like you know what let's let's
have those people over their bin Studios
have them start on it and then you know
what naughty dog just finished Last of
Us Part Two let's have them finish it
but it's Last of Us Part One I know that
but we bored you started you finish it
but we all have unique ideas I don't
care what your ideals are you started
you finish it and then you see this
recent uh these recent news where people
are talking about uh they formally came
out and said games are going to be at
least a year difference
uh so coming out on PC so at least a
year so all this thing out finally be
put away where people's like addict but
I think with their you know by the time
we get the next the next uh
uh PlayStation exclusive it's gonna be
like three four years later no wrong
wrong
and right now a year right now yeah
right now it's a year
eventually you're gonna have these games
come out like six months and then yep
and then six months gonna turn into
three months so three let's go turn into
day and day at it next six is busy
brother they're trying to catch up
they're catching up they're porting go
so sushi but last of us too they're
catching up then they still have the
port
uh uh what's the damn name uh like
forbidden West I can think the name they
have to Port that they have the port gt7
they have to pour God of War Ragnarok
they're catching up once they catch up
guess what's going to happen they're
already gonna pour returnal they gotta
pour a wrestling Clank they're going to
eventually catch up
and when they catch up day and day they
Liz
damn day it is watch two dollars from
flame My article is focused around the
uh this remaster
it's just
I just don't understand it man and then
you know even if they have a third party
or a second party and like gorilla isn't
even making I'm pretty sure girl is the
one that makes a horizon
it's a waste of resources like you could
have found better things to do with this
and part of me feels like because
they're getting into the TV scenario
where they're The Last of Us and maybe
that's the reason that they push for
this last of us part one and that's the
reason you've seen the movie come out
and it's interesting that they they
remade Last of Us Part One after they
remastered it in 2014 right and then
a TV show comes out like a year to six
months after I don't know when the TV
show comes out and now you're hearing
rumors and I think it might have been
confirmed that there's going to be a
horizon zero Dawn show
and now you're hearing about a remaster
to the show so what's funny is they're
they're making business decisions based
off what their IPs are doing in a
different industry
and I don't think that's a good move
that's like the equivalent to like
making a Spider-Man game because you
wanted to come out around the same time
that the Spider-Man movie comes out so
once the game flops once if people like
I played this I don't need to do this
and then before you why the Ben Studios
making it they're making Horizon zero
Dawn on the side and then what ends up
happening is the game doesn't do what
it's supposed to do and they have to
shut down Ben Studio which is not their
fault
because they didn't meet expectations
it's just it's crazy that they would
choose to make another Horizon over a
new IP yeah yeah I agree it's crazy that
they wasted not necessarily waste I'm
sure last of us will still make money
but it's crazy that they they spent and
dedicated all that time with Last of Us
Part One
instead of making a new game
hey Alex there's a guy in the chat named
truth serum he said this is just a bad
Sony show okay sir what would you prefer
us to talk about right now
what's funny we're talking about the
most recent gaming news and uh we're
giving our opinions on the most recent
gaming news so what would you prefer us
to talk about right now the crazy The
Last of Us Part One rebuleased is
amazing yes what do you want us to talk
about
the funny part
is I'm getting tired of uh people
talking like that because it's like King
says
King every week comes to IOP with some
anti-playstation topic it's not King's
fault that PlayStation continues to give
this man weekly ammunition to use
against him I'm saying it is what it is
like Eric the beard crying about what
we're talking about
it's just like
I think
I think the the word
what's what I'm looking for
accountability comes into play
because it's like I feel like Xbox and
Nintendo to some degree not every time
Nintendo usually gets away with a lot of
stuff too but I always feel like
Nintendo and Sony get away with a lot of
things that PlayStation doesn't
like if imagine if XBox came to you and
said the only way you could talk to
customer service
is if you are if you're a gold member
they would get laughed out of the room
murdered
they will be destroyed bro am I like
instead of you got you know smart play
or whatever uh smart delivery they say
we're gonna charge you ten dollars for
every game that you buy on Xbox One to
convert to an Xbox series that's an X
they'd get murdered
you know we got what if they made Gears
like gears five they re like they did a
remake of Gears five coming out of 2023.
it would get murdered
it would be murdered come on man I'm
just saying bro I'm seeing guys say I
see the guy Eric the bear say they're
working on projects
and I think about the other parts is
when we talk about future XBox projects
we say uh Xboxes you know y'all Xbox
have no games you said where they're
working on projects
they still have no games
okay and the sad part is we call them
out at every corner we literally just
was saying at the beginning of this show
like you know Halo's in a bad spot they
need change yeah but you guys don't say
anything you you completely overlooked
that but the moment we start talking bad
about PlayStation
then people sit there and say you guys
are talking down on place they should
know you guys aren't doing enough it's
the reason look what happened when Xbox
tried to stop giving what people get
this misconception when when the price
of gold went up it wasn't because they
increased gold they stopped giving you
discounts on gold they were going to
stop giving you the 50 discount and make
you pay full price for gold people spoke
up and it got fixed
hey
everyone spoke up it wasn't one side of
one the other the whole industry said
this ain't right it got fixed
Sony has had that happen every now and
then but for the most part they get away
with everything
you know I remember when what didn't
Sony say you you had to buy I don't know
if it is now but in order to get the
remaster of the original Spider-Man you
had to buy the deluxe edition yeah the
PS5 version to get the PS5 version of
Spider-Man
I don't even know if they got fixed yeah
like it's just like that is that kind of
mentality is crazy to me and it's like
those kind of business practices why we
talk about it's not because it'd be
different if we was if we was reaching
we just reaching but we're not reaching
this this is actually there it's it's in
the news and it's it's in the new It's
weekly Sony does stuff weekly that
messes up the industry in some way shape
or form regardless if it's the gaming
portion of the side of the consumer
portion of the site weekly okay attic
now let me say this from my point of
view because you are you know how my
channel is right now for those of you
like Eric the beard and true Sam if you
guys don't like this like what we're
talking about right now you definitely
don't want to come to my child because I
would let you guys know what my channel
is
his channel is awesome definitely y'all
are going to hate it right so you
probably don't want to come to my
channel but with that being said it's me
and my boy Sean was just talking about
this he's like man he's in that
PlayStation has been in the news
consistently the last two and a half
three months and it's been nothing good
so yes we've been talking trash
my channel we talking trash my podcast
we talk trash
etiquette they're not like me King David
he talks trash Alex joins in on the fun
sometime but I'm not trying to
feel to myself when it comes to this
because you guys know how I am when it
was last generation when Xbox was having
these self-inflicted wounds
PlayStation guys let them have let XBox
guys have it let Xbox have it and it was
justified you know what I feel like it
is and correctly if I'm wrong or but I
did feel like in some ways a lot of the
hardcore PlayStation fanboys
they're entitled
they expect Sony to act one way and
anyone to say anything against Sony they
get upset over
you know
we were I literally was just saying god
of war is coming out in November
probably one of the best games this year
you didn't talk about that did you no
you left that apart you left that alone
and
and it just
we got to be better on calling out both
companies including Nintendo Nintendo
gets away more than any of them uh you
know they they can make whatever type of
game they want you know people are going
to go up to even even the game about
shooting people will paint you're not
gonna get away with that you know
Microsoft Sony make a game shooting
about paint
Dirk what's gonna happen
oh man this works the Sea of Thieves
doing I'm a grown man what is this
foolishness if if I wanted to paint I
would go paint like I don't need a game
to shoot paint wait it is what it is you
know when it comes to this it's just
like look I'd like to see more original
IPS uh it would be different guys you
know if the chat if we were getting like
a big showcase hour and a half new IPS
new experiences outside of like
Wolverine
and like the Ronin
and Spider-Man what what's what's down
the pipeline for them nobody knows and
that's why they didn't have a showcase
because they have nothing ready to show
and that's the funny thing it's just
like dude like we don't just attack
people for no reason and we're talking
clinies not people but it's like we want
better you know we we tax Sony when it's
necessary and we attack Microsoft and
Nintendo when it's necessary but
unfortunately for the chat
Sony just be dropping the ball all the
time they'd be horrible at playing
basketball yeah like they couldn't score
anything you're much nicer than me I'm
sorry guys where was you Eric the beer
were you around last generation where
were you at when Xbox was being smacked
on a daily basis where were you at with
every podcast
would be bashing Xbox where were you at
then huh
please tell me please tell me
because I really want to know because
you know what I used to listen to
podcasts and I was like damn they're
killing Xbox but guess what I didn't cry
in the chat y'all keep on talking bad
about Xbox you know I didn't cry about
that I just didn't listen
how about that
I'm sorry I had to go here you're fine
we got a five dollar Super Chat from Jay
Roberts Roberts I don't know man uh did
you all hear that Brazil
APK I tagged you in from a tweet from uh
Benji cells I appreciate it man yeah we
heard about the song earlier it's just
like look that Deal's going through
there's no way around that like you
don't have Satya coming out with some
broad strong statements like he's been
making and it's not going through like
pretty much I bet you the lawyers like
companies like this don't really make
these you know and I will say this when
this deal is done when it's over and
that and they put that bowl
don't be surprised if they announce more
Studios being bought because I know it's
coming it's coming and and you know I
I'm a I'm gonna do back Strokes in in in
the in the in the lake full of uh Sony
Fanboy tears when it happens hey yo Eric
the beard once this deal is uh like
finalized don't come don't come to my
channel you don't want to come to my
channel brother Trust and Believe
you won't like it
look Eric I could swim very well okay
I'm out of shape these days you know be
eating a little bit too chicken a little
too much chicken but I can I can I can I
could do it man I can swim if I had to
maybe not long but I could definitely
swim if I had to but you know that
that's pretty much like all I got going
on for the show uh you know I I just
it's like I said man I just want I want
everyone to do I want the industry to do
better uh as far as like PR concerns I
got my own concerns with PR too I feel
like they needed to be a little more
open with uh content creators sometimes
it's hard to get a hold of these people
it it's frustrating because
I feel like there's a lot of people in
the industry that just says like natural
access and they break in ndas and stuff
and then you got people that you know
really put in their work and they they
don't get that benefit and you know it's
sad man it's sad like uh I wanted to try
out the uh the ninja game for uh uh for
the for the Nintendo game the the Mario
game the Mario rabbits couldn't get a
hold of anyone no one would respond to
emails it's it's it's a shame man it's a
shame so I don't know if I'm gonna
review that game because uh I don't like
playing really anything on the switch to
be completely 100 honest with you it
just games just run but now I have if
I'm reviewing something I will play it
I'm going to be reviewing the Pokemon
game because I really enjoyed the
Pokemon franchise but I don't like doing
it because I feel like the game could
just run better on a different platform
but anyway you know
so Aaron says unbad me from your your
channel bro I like teaching yes oh me
you must have pissed off like you must
have pissed on one of my mods bro I
look at it I don't remember seeing you
being on my channel maybe you're being
on shine Channel I don't know
man what's funny is you know I don't
know about your situation Aaron but I
don't understand how people get banned
and like beg for forgiveness
like well see I think it's a little bit
different too because like obviously if
Aaron got banned off IOP there's amount
a number of people that could do it so
maybe like it could have been a Miss
because I have seen people get uh by
accident Yeah by accident or the mod
just don't like them and it's not even
for any remote reason uh yeah so he the
man said he'll look into it okay can't
promise you anything but he'll look into
it but you know Xbox one was trash they
gotta admit it oh so that's probably why
you gotta block dude
I've been banned by oh my God so Eric
the Beards man from your chat too
nah like lethal pop is not a mind on my
channel so oh I never seen Eric the
beard on my channel before trust me he
won't like it
um
see this is the thing though
um I'm I'm telling you this man I had
gotta uh BM from a fan well I only like
to say fan of a listener of a supporter
of my channel and he said dirt thank you
bro I'm tired of ponies sometimes we
just need a safe haven away from them
because it's gonna everywhere I go every
Pro Xbox Channel I go to even though my
channel when you talk a lot of trash
yourself sometimes I just want to kick
it talk trash have fun
anyways I'm tired of these ponies man he
said sometimes we need to Safe Haven
away from them and not the last
generation I feel them
that's why you know obviously we have
like Eric the beard and stuff we have
like real Pro PlayStation people as long
as you guys ain't like
disrespectful most the time I'll let you
I'll let you slide in there you know as
long as you ain't disrespectful to
anyone in my chat or definitely just put
people on my panel like that's the
quickest way you getting out of here is
if you disrespect people on the panel
it's just like you know keep keep it
you could keep it messy just don't don't
cross lines and you guys know what lines
not to cross everyone knows what lines
not to cross stop stop acting like you
don't you know what lines not to cross
then go Teo Walker that's the one that
left that DM thanks bro I know you was
here
um hey Eric the bear bro I'm telling you
you won't like my channel man you might
as well unsubscribe right now telling
you bro I'm telling you won't like it
you're gonna see Eric he holding back
here
I'm telling you bro you won't like it
see that's that's eight years of pent up
frustration from getting my legs beat
last generation from PlayStation Fanboys
that's what my channel is I'm telling
you right now dirt is coming to you
right now as a Super Saiyan Goku
but if you go on his channel he gonna be
a full-blown Ultra Instinct Goku and I
don't know if you've noticed it but you
can't hit Goku he's too he he just be
doing some slide stuff you know you try
to hit him he just jumps up bends
backwards like like
like I just got one thing that one thing
to say Pier are you ready for the smoke
oh man I don't know if we ready man
trust me we'll see though we'll see
we're going to uh close this out man all
right bro all right so we we hour and 46
minutes and uh thanks man I feel I feel
better man I'm feeling I'm starting to
feel a little better man and this was
fun thanks bro anyway hour and 46
minutes and it will get the time stops
right you know the mafia are going to be
afternoon yeah one day I'm just gonna
open the door and I'm just I'm just
gonna hear one little noise and that's
gonna be over let's go
it's gonna be death Luke hey sucker what
a tab stamps Who Am you they go I'm
gonna be buried like two feet in the
backyard right hey
they didn't feel like to bury me deep in
my hands like the tip of my fingers
see your fingers like this
time steps oh my God they ride on my
Tombstone the dude who should have wrote
time stamps and he'd still be around
right now
all right but uh
dirt where can the people find you out
beard you gotta remember man what he
about to say I'm telling you going there
at your own at your own risk man uh now
yeah man um I might leave my channel in
the chat listen
um I saw Corey said I'm not uh what he
said he isn't Pro Xbox as I place this
no I am Pro Xbox bro I'm beyond Pro Xbox
I'm not anti-playstation it might it
might seem like that lately because of
the news I'm not anti-playstation but I
am anti-playstation Fanboy like I told
you guys
you can hear the passion the frustration
just you know sometimes from
get my legs beat for eight years
straight last generation and uh so yeah
we're having a good time um yeah for my
my um channel in the chat have a good
time I Am pro Xbox uh
I'm not anti-play sex I enjoy the
PlayStation I really do God Awards one
of my favorite franchises I can't wait
for Ragnarok but we do have fun and it's
just sometimes it's at the PlayStation
Fanboy expense
thank you yeah so you know spam that
chat 2 A.M yeah uh so you know
definitely go there and sub to the to
the mans if you if you guys want that
that smoke man and you know he it's a
joking thing don't go in there and think
anything he's saying like sincere unless
unless you come at him he's not going to
come at you with content uh but I
appreciate it for coming through man
we're going to uh be ending this like I
said you guys could catch me this Sunday
at 1pm I don't know if we're having a
guest I can't remember even if I did I
couldn't tell you uh but definitely come
in 1 p.m uh I am reviewing diofeled I
already beat the game I'm reviewing it
currently I'm in the process of making
the review hopefully they'll be up
tomorrow and then I gotta jump straight
on to another game but uh appreciate it
for coming through and until next time
this is addict and Dirk griggity and we
out of here